c'est autant pour la reine que pour
l'ambiance qu'ils sont venus et pour
être vu autant que pour voir
c'est de toute beauté s'exclame irene je
suis si heureuse d'être ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ceux qui se sont hissés dans les
premiers rangs sur le mall ont pu voir
défiler les quelques 1500 soldats 200
chevaux et 450 musiciens
mais surtout tour à tour les membres de
la famille royale s'est vêtu de la tenue
militaire et à cheval que se sont
déplacés les héritiers de la reine le
prince charles william et la princesse
anne et
duchesse de cambridge kate les trois
enfants du couple royal et camilla la
duchesse de cornouailles ont quant à eux
parcouru le mall à bord d'un carrosse
pour la toute première fois depuis
qu'elle est sur le trône c'est le prince
charles qui a reçu le salut à la reine
cette dernière a quand même tenu à faire
une première apparition surprise au
balcon accompagné de son cousin le duc
de kent
70 hélicoptères et avions pour 70 ans de
règne une finale tonitruante au dessus
de vos king and palaces
entouré des membres de la famille royale
la reine a offert une foule conquise et
sans doute soulagé de la revoir cette
image qui viendra définir le jubilé de
platine seuls les membres actifs de la
famille étaient invités au balcon ni
harry meyen bien qu'ils ont assisté aux
célébrations
ni le prince andrew qui lui s'est dit
atteint de l'aco vide n'était présent
tout sourire la reine avait l'air
enchanté du spectacle
elle peut pas en dire autant de son
arrière petit fils louis qui devient
ravi la vedette
[Musique]
le temps de quelques grimaces bien senti
la fête se poursuit jusqu'à dimanche la
reine a beaucoup apprécié la journée
mais elle a ressenti un certain malaise
a fait savoir le palais royal en soirée
elle ne sera donc pas à la cérémonie
religieuse prévue demain ici marie-eve
bédard radio-canada londres